also das reicht von kommentaren wo ich
sagen würde die sind doof aber keine us
nachrichten also um leute schreiben das
ist schlecht für die herzgesundheit bis
hin zu beleidigungen [ __ ] widerliche
stück bis hin zu langen beschreibungen
wo leute sagen wie es ja gerne
vergewaltigen und töten würden
ricarda lang von den grünen ist eine der
ganz ganz wenigen politiker innen die
sich öffentlich über das äußern weil sie
jeden tag sehen wenn sie in ihre social
media kanäle gucken hat euch das
geschockt wenn ihr auch regelmäßig in
den sozialen medien unterwegs hat
wahrscheinlich nicht hast dort ist ein
fast schon altes phänomen aber
nichtsdestotrotz ein großes problem dann
ist es brandgefährlich was für
auswirkungen das auf politiker innen hat
auf unsere demokratie
was aber auch die politik selbst dazu
beigetragen hat dass es überhaupt dazu
kommen konnte und was die politik aber
auch wir alle tun können damit aus der
gosse zu der social media inzwischen
verkommen ist wieder eine fußgängerzone
wird darum geht es heute
wir kommen bei insight politik mein name
ist nicole diekmann und ich bin
korrespondentin im zdf hauptstadtstudio
das ist walter lübke walter lübke war
cdu politiker war der lücke wurde
erschossen 2009 10
zuvor war er jahrelang in den sozialen
netzwerken verhetzt verhasst und bedroht
worden denn lübke regierungspräsident in
kassel hatte sich während der
sogenannten flüchtlingskrise für die
aufnahme von geflüchteten eingesetzt
sein mörder ist ein neonazi all das ist
kein zufall hat mir christoph heneka
erzählt becker bei der erste
staatsanwalt in deutschland der sich
ausschließlich mit hass rede im netz
beschäftigt hat
warum die kommentare aus dem rechten und
rechtsextremen raum
das was wir in unseren
ermittlungsverfahren sehen kommt von
rechts und das ist nicht so dass wir
hingehen und gezielt gegen rechte us
kommentare vorgehen sondern es so dass
unsere echter hass kommentare angezeigt
werden wir würden genauso gut
linksradikale verfolgen wenn er uns dann
angezeigt würde wir sehen aber sehr sehr
wenig davon
das bestätigen uns auch analystinnen die
schützenswerten die daten sind eindeutig
der hass im netz kommt ganz überwiegend
aus der rechten ecke es ist deshalb auch
kein zufall dass der jüngste versuch der
bundesregierung des hasses im netz herr
zu werden
in ein gesetz gegossen wurde das heißt
gesetz zur bekämpfung der
hasskriminalität und des
rechtsextremismus dieses gesetz ist eine
direkte reaktion auf den mord an walter
lübke sein name kommt darin auch vor das
gesetz zusammengefasst die plattformen
wie facebook twitter aber zb auch
youtube sollen dazu gezwungen werden mit
den strafverfolgungsbehörden enger
zusammenzuarbeiten
die behörden wiederum sollen mehr
personal bekommen und so
gesetzesverstöße im netz konsequenter
ahnten können das gesetz ist außerdem
ein versuch das netzwerk durchsetzungs
gesetz kurz netz.de zu verbessern
das trat 2017 in kraft und war auch
schon der versuch hass und hetze im netz
einzudämmen hat wie wir sehen nur
bedingt funktioniert hinter der reform
jetzt steckt unter anderem
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer und
das ist gut so denn wenn jemand den
titel digital native verdient hat dann
horst seehofer sich auch sehr im
internet unterwegs bin nicht so sehr mit
ihnen und mit twitter usw
seit den achtziger jahren
das ist insofern ziemlich beeindruckend
als zivilist innen in den 80er jahren
noch gar nicht möglich war im internet
unterwegs zu sein aber es ist nicht nur
horst seehofer ob die cdu und hilfloser
umgang mit dem video von wiso oder der
grüne parteichef robert habeck der
zweimal quasi denselben fehler auf
twitter machte und daraufhin seinen
account gleich ganz löschte fast alle
bundestagsparteien haben social media
verschlafen und dem entsprechenden
nachholbedarf
inzwischen besitzen zwar sagt eine
studie von 2009 10 77 prozent der
bundestagsabgeordneten einen social
media kanal vorher aber war tote hose
2008 zb da gewann barack obama die us
war nicht zuletzt wegen social media er
hatte sich übrigens einen mitbegründer
von facebook mit in sein wahlkampf-team
geholt
späten die abgeordneten die politiker
innen hierzulande noch pacman und so
konnten die tech riesen lange zeit
unbeobachtet und unreguliert ihre macht
ausbauen und das gift konnte sich quasi
unkontrolliert seinen weg bahnen
mittlerweile auch aus ins analoge leben
bei mir wurde jetzt letzte woche auf
meinem klingelschild bei mir in der
wohnung bewohne mehrfamilienhaus das
heißt mehrere namen dem klingelschild
und genau mein name der von mitbewohner
der auch politiker ist rot
durchgestrichen wo man natürlich glas
sieht das war jetzt ein kinderstreich wo
alles voll gesucht wurde sondern sollte
ein klares zeichen sein
wir wissen wo du wohnst der
spd-politiker karl lauterbach ist
gesundheitsexperte und seit corona auf
allen kanälen unterwegs was ihm in den
sozialen netzwerken so entgegenschlägt
hat er bei uns im zdf mal
zusammengefasst
ich bin nah am freitag zu später stunde
bin ich noch mal durch die büros
gegangen mein team war weg da hab ich
einfach mal geguckt was liegt auf den
staatlichen normen getaner arbeit man
wirklich auf jeden schreibtisch lagen
also drucksachen also von ermittler
behörden also von staatsanwalt
korrespondenz mit staatsanwaltschaften
also screenshots zu weit vor so auf
jedem start ich meine team mitarbeiter
verlags quasi ermittlungs zeug
beleidigen sagt das ist also fast schon
an der dimension ein haus waren wir
nicht so klar
die recherche gruppe die insider macht
hassbotschaften in geschlossenen gruppen
öffentlich und hat uns ein paar
screenshots überlassen vielen dank dafür
nochmal so unterhalten sich leute über
karl lauterbach gleich erschießen das
ist meine meinung kann man diesen
menschen nicht entsorgen oder ist das
gefährlicher sondermüll knallt den
spastiker endlich ab ich kann die dumme
fresse nicht mehr sehen da kommt eh nur
müll raus so etwas kann man natürlich
melden das kann man auch anzeigen und
das sollte man auch unbedingt sogar wie
geht ihr damit um wenn ihr haus im netz
seht meldet ihr zeigt ihr an
helft ihr betroffenen ein weiteres
riesiges problem
man kommt an die leute die so etwas
schreiben fast nie heran
die plattform rücken die daten nicht
raus die staatsanwaltschaften sind
unterbesetzt verfahren versandten
durchaus menschen nachvollziehen die das
netz als rechtsfreien raum empfinden
oder dass es zumindest innerhalb des
netz einige rechtsfreie möglicherweise
gefühlte rechtsfreie räume gibt
natürlich gelten da die regeln sie
werden bloß in thailand schlicht und
einfach nicht durchgesetzt und das sagt
ein staatsanwalt das ist schon krass
oder
das alles sei für sie schon sehr
belastend sagt ricarda lang
trotzdem wollen sie und auch karl
lauterbach sich nicht einschüchtern
lassen die masse macht natürlich auch
was mit einem ist es vielleicht manchmal
weniger verletzungen aber doch moment ja
auch von angst von habe ich gerade die
zeit mich den auszusetzen habe ich die
kraft mich dem auszusetzen muss ich kann
ihnen versichern was ich auch nie
darüber nachdenken wenn ich irgendetwas
sagen oder wenn ich etwas formulieren
wie gefällt das den querdenker weil wir
gefällt das den tätern im netz also ich
versichere ihnen das könnte mir nicht
egal sein also an dem punkt ich
definitiv noch nicht angekommen dass es
meine arbeit war es wissen würde für ein
paar wochen gab es übrigens einen
farbanschlag auf das auto
lauterbach ricarda lang aber auch
staatsanwalt christoph herr becker
erzählt übereinstimmt dass der hass seit
corona in den netzwerken noch mal
schlimmer geworden ist und die grünen
berichten dass die hass nachrichten
zugenommen haben seitdem annalena
baerbock zur kanzlerkandidatin erklärt
wurde
hättet ihr dann noch lust in die politik
zu gehen für die demokratie ziemlich
schlecht wenn es keiner mehr machen will
oder wissenschaftler innen berichten
inzwischen von einem zeilen singh effekt
einem verstoß effekt der auch bei
politiker innen bewirkt dass sie sich in
den sozialen netzwerken nicht mehr so
äußern wie sie es eigentlich würden oder
ihre accounts gleich ganz löschen
ein gesetz gegen hass kriminalität und
gegen rechtsradikalismus ist es dass
jetzt ist aus der game changer hier
kommen drei schritte die die politik
gehen muss erstens facebook und die
anderen netz riesen sind inzwischen viel
zu mächtig wenn man sie wirklich dazu
zwingen will mitzumachen beim kampf
gegen den hass im netz
dann müssen sich viele staaten
zusammenschließen gesetze verabschieden
und dann auch wirklich durchsetzen
zweitens braucht geld es braucht geld
für mehr leute in den polizeiwachen bei
den staatsanwaltschaften und an den
gerichten damit diese leute zeit und
kapazitäten haben um gegen diejenigen
vorzugehen die das gift versprühen jeden
tag denn den sozialen
zwecken und drittens politiker innen
müssen sich breitmachen in den
netzwerken
sie müssen zeigen wie man kommuniziert
konstruktiv und respektvoll
das war es von mir ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen falls ja lasst ein leichter und
abonniert uns ihr dürft auch gerne
kommentieren und kritisieren aber bitte
friedlich und falls ihr noch mehr zu dem
thema wissen möchtet